وفي تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا افادت
الاداره العسكريه لمنطقه الاوكرانيه بان
القوات الروسيه هاجمت مواقع للبنيه
التحتيه بالصواريخ الليله الماضيه وفي
المقابل اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه في
بيان افشاله محاوله اوكرانيه لضرب اهداف
في شبه جزيره القرم ورستوف وكالوجا
بصواريخ اسم 200 المضاده للطائرات
والمعدات المعدله لتدمير ادف ارضيه واشار
البيان الى ان انظمه الدفاع الجويه اسقطت
اربعه صواريخ دون ان يؤدي ذلك الى اضرار
او اصابات
وكلف رئيس هيئه اركان القوات الروسيه
فاليري جراسيموم في اول ظهور له منذ تمرد
قوات فاجنر الشارع الماضي كلف الاستخبارات
الروسيه وقياده المجموعه المشتركه باتخاذ
التدابير اللازمه لتعزيز المنشاه من
الضربات الجويه وفق البيان
اذا بروجيا قالت الاداره العسكريه في
المنطقه ان القوات الروسيه استهدفت بشكل
متعمد مركزا لتوزيع المساعدات الانسانيه
في بلده اوريخوف وخلف الهجوم مقتل اربعه
اشخاص وجرحى احد عشر اخرين
واضافات الاداره العسكريه في الجيش الروسي
استهدف 10 بلدات اخرى فيزا ما ادى لوقوع
جرحى وتضرر مبانئ سكنيه
افاد حاكم مقاطعه الروسيه ان القوات
الاوكرانيه اطلقت باتجاه المقاطعه 26
قذيفه خلال الساعات الاربعه والعشرين
الماضيه دون تسجيل اصابه او اضرار وفي بخت
وقال موقع ريبار العسكري الروسي ان القوات
الروسيه تصدت لمحاولات هجوميه اوكرانيه
باتجاه بلدك ليشفكا جنوبيه مدينه باغموت
وفي مقاطعه لوغانسك اشار الموقع الروسي
الى ان القوات الروسيه تشن هجمات على محور
في المقاطعه
على صعيد اخر نددت السفاره الروسيه في
الولايات المتحده بقرار امريكا ارسال
ذخائر عنقوديه الى اوكرانيا قالت السفاره
الروسيه ان البيت الابيض يعترف فعليا
بارتكاب جرائم حرب بعد الموافقه على ارسال
ذخائر عنقوديه الى اوكرانيا